alors denise tu peux c'est l'une des
boîtes de nuit les plus originales de la
capitale comment on pourrait la définir
si tu me connaissait pas on se rend
compte tous les deux sur une plage la
costa brava et tu m'expliques tu
m'expliquer ce que tu fais comment tu
racontes traite à boîte doit être sympa
quoi où les gens font ce qu'ils ont
envie de faire
ouais genre quoi par exemple
tout ce qui leur passe par la tête ouais
c'est tout ce que tu dirais mais on est
tous les deux sur la plage sur la page
selouane la poule at il a beaucoup de
poids comme ça à paris oui avec quelques
pluies
ouais mais dans mon style je pense que
je suis la seule à faire cela tienne
c'est la plus sympa quand même
c'est à dire que moi j'ai un grand côté
discothèque
ouais il deschamps peuvent lancer way et
pourquoi tu as changé de dress on boit
pas de lait la presse et la télévision
on peut pas la donne et je suis heureuse
parce que
je vous la donne non non c'est pas loin
d'ici
c'est pas très important c'est bien tout
plein vol
mais pourquoi tu as changé leur hausse
je devais changer l'adresse parce que
le propriétaire j'étais enfant on n'a
plus une question d'honneur ne
supportait pas alors je
c'est pourquoi ça en
discothèque dévoile dans ce genre qui
sont très connus il ya le roi rené
le cléopâtre je n'ai rien de commun avec
c
qu'est ce qui est différent chez moi on
danse avant tout d'accords fiscaux
oui mais ça se passe comment une soirée
chez soi par exemple en baisse
se passe comme dans tout ça
j'en arrive
arrivons - valeur en temps et j'en ai
mes amis
où je les présente à votre personne
jusqu'à nice pas ça y paraît qui fait ça
très bien
bah oui j'adore que je sais bien
représenter les gens les uns aux autres
ce qu'ils vont bien s'entendre entre eux
et c'est parce qu'il ya des gentils
qu'ils ne sont jamais allés vers
d'autres donc je crois que c'est
l'essentiel ils font les présenter il
faudrait mettre en contact il faut les
obliger à bouger surtout parce que je
crois que les gens actuellement ont
tendance à se laisser vivre
étape à une baisse de fréquentation ce
moment avec les
qui rôde un peu partout dans tout ça
marche toujours aussi minable c'est quoi
le meilleur jour chez toi mais c'est
dans les boîtiers toujours un meilleur
jour il n'y a pas de nuages à voir il ya
des jours où il ya plus de monde que
d'habitude il n'y a pas de mots c'est
pas forcément les jours
il ya beaucoup de monde samedi
demande vendredi réaliser
quel que soit le
mercredi c'est très sympa fabrique des
choses qui fait la particularité de la
boîte s'appelle comment est on dit on
dit chez devises à une des choses qui
fait la particularité de pub là tu sais
qu'on envoie des stars à il ya beaucoup
de gens très connus et ce qui était
assez sympathique finalement c'est que
ces gens connus n'hésite pas quand ils
sont chez toi se livrer à des jeux
érotiques disant comment ça se fait ça
non non non non mais je pense qu'ils
viennent chez moi parce que
ils se sentent bien d'abord ouais parce
que je suis très ami
que mais viennent pas pour le jeu
ruth normes qui viennent parce que parce
que ça les amuse puis se sent bien chez
eux
je fais ça depuis longtemps sept ans
sept ans mais celle d'avant on peut dire
où elle était finalement 98 et plus non
sinon tu veux pas non plus toujours pour
le propriétaire non mais si tu précis
mais qu'est ce que tu faisais avant de
faire ça j'ai fait des films à bord oui
j'aime pas ça non
oui je vois la production ouais et
commentent allait arriver à faire ça
devient une loi qui chez nous ce type
je crois que du film x 7 wet seal et
rentrent pas ouais et les projets de la
production ont finalement su recoller
n'y a pas de caméra pas exactement
tu vas faire ça longtemps non je pense
pas non mais en maroc à z
ouais ça rapporte de l'argent et sur
ciné je ferai pas beaucoup d'argent
penser que c'est un produit car j'ai pas
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent c'est comme
toutes les discothèques
c'est quoi le truc le pire qu'ils soient
passés chez toi
qu'ils soient passés chez warhol pur le
plus marrant il ya beaucoup de gags
marrant ou par exemple un jour une mère
enfin le maire pendant l couple arrive
et la dame discute avec moi descendez
l'escalier et d'un seul coup elle
s'arrête net
n'est-il pas possible je ne peux pas
rester chez moi sortir tout de suite ou
dessus il ya mon fils or à ouidah corps
comment on peut rentrer chez toi il faut
être présentées par les gens qui
fréquentent déjà avant ce genre club
alors oui et une fois janvier il faut
venir avec le temps d'un garçon
accompagné sur bien tout seul ça marche
pas il ya des gens des fois qu'ils
savent pas que c'est une boîte comme ça
et tout en vous rendant au nom ça si ça
va sur toute façon vous 3 way je termine
tard n'ont pas trop tard
animal